What's up, guys?
I saw the announcement from
Casey that he is stopped his
daily vlog and so we're going to
try to step up and deliver for
all the people that are
super sad and try to do
DailyVee actually daily.
We got to come up with different
concepts because there's family
time and different things
I don't normally show but
we're going to step up.
I'm here filming "Planet of
the Apps" and so I'm getting my
hustle on and I hope
you enjoy today's show.
(upbeat R&amp;B)
Sometimes DRock forgets
I'm actually running my
career and business here.
Couldn't you and Tyler put some
bullshit down here or somewhere
that says, "In LA or something"
so I can on my merry way and
make shit happen?
Unlike traditional
platforms where NBC
had a contract with,
you know, the stars of "Friends"
and the monetization was shared
there is no loyalty for
influencer to a platform whether
that's Vine,
Instagram or Snapchat,
and by they way, nor should
there be so we have a whole new
set of rules and a whole new
world and I think that that is
absolutely impacting...
The tension and the curious
nature of like how does it play
out between
influencers and platforms.
Again, will we get into a world
where the YouTube's and the
Facebooks and the
Snapchats look more like NBC,
ABC and CBS and they're
signing exclusive deals?
Maybe.
I mean if this continues to be
conversation can Logan Paul sign
an exclusive deal with Instagram
and only live there and and get
generate an upfront,
you know, dollar amount
and then rev share.
Maybe, I do know but
I definitely know that the basic
friction or perceived friction
since it's the same at every
platform because at its highest
point it's is Coca-Cola and
Pepsi's money going
to me and Logan Paul
and Arielle or is it
going to Musical.ly,
Snapchat, Instagram
or Facebook, right?
I got a big idea so this
is really weird the way
I'm positioning it to
you so stick with me,
you've gotta keep it to yourself
and if there's anything like
tell me what you're thinking.
What I think I try to do is
put the best ingredients on the
table and then work with you on
being the co-chefs
to figure it out.
Do you see where I'm going?
Listen, surprise and delight,
you know how influencers all of
a sudden the 60 minutes thing
like it's all of a sudden like
becoming a very real thing?
Surprise and delight is
gonna be the same thing in 2019.
Keep that as a seed in
the back of your mind,
'cause I'm gonna be a
broken record because I'll win.
Either you'll do stuff and we'll
win together or you won't and in
2019 you be like,
"Fuck, good call."
You now?
I wish we could
show the real shit.
- [DRock] (laughs) I know.
- People would be blown away.
- How comfortable
are you changing?
- [Gary] Very.
- Okay.
("Standing 2" by Duke Westlake)
- [Gary] I think every brand in the
2017 environment has to have a
presence, Facebook is television
and if you don't understand that
then you're just
not paying attention,
you're not a practitioner or you
have some other financial vested
interest to not believe that and
the quicker you understand that
more people consume videos to
sell stuff on Facebook than they
do to watch a
television commercial,
not a television show to sell
stuff the quicker your business
will be successful.
Just filmed something for a
client maybe DRock can show a
little clip of it and
just do music over it.
That was fun.
Just did some wardrobe
check for "Planet of the Apps".
It's getting all Hollywood out
in here and just in LA for the
day, couple of meetings,
going to a big client pitch,
couple other biz dev
meetings after that.
Couple phone calls,
deep in VaynerMedia world,
you know, some
organizational changes,
some real offense for 2017.
I'm fired up a lot of big
business opportunities and
really feeling aligned with
my leadership team and feeling
aligned with you
guys in the community.
Pumping out content 24/7/365.
I mean, Jesus,
people didn't even,
there was meetings I was in
the 2011 where executives didn't
even know what Facebook was
even though it was four or
five years old and monstrous.
Not only is that not happened,
it went from
little to no knowledge to
disrespect in '13, '14, right?
To that doesn't mean
anything, who cares,
that's an afterthought to now
there is not an executive on
Earth in the marketing media
business world that is willing
to have massive audacity to
disrespect this
environment, right?
They might not believe in it but
nobody's pounding their chest
and peacocking in a boardroom
saying Facebook's
gonna be gone in a year.
You know what I mean?
Sports Illustrated or ESPN
should've built
Bleacher Report, right?
Condé should have build
Refinery29 or Pure Well, right?
So I'm a big believer,
Marriott should built airBnB.
You know, I don't feel some
transportation company
shoulda created Uber.
That's my general thesis
of when you're the leader,
create an allocation of dollars
to put yourself out of business
before somebody else does.
To do what I just
said means that the CEO,
the board, and the other leaders
in every organization have to
have worse numbers for three
years 'cause they're pouring
dollars into something that
doesn't return anything and
that's not in their bonus
structure a positive thing so
human behavior takes over and
they appease Wall Street in
90 day terms, don't invest in
the future and they don't care
'cause they're
retiring in four years.
This is historical.
What happens is,
what happens is we
wake up one day and major
media companies that we
grew up with are gone.
Of course it is because the
Wall Street Journal and
Sports Illustrated and USA Today
and the New York Post they
killed somebody else, too.
And radio and TV will still
be around and people will buy
commercials 20 years from now
but they won't pay as much and
it won't be as important.
Nothing dies, nothing dies
things just get exposed.
By the way, I have
no vested interest,
I'll be the first guy that talks
this way about Facebook and
Snapchat if I don't
think they're ROI positive.
I'm completely agnostic.
I'll give you another thing, if
the New York Times wants to cut
their full-page ad rates
by 75% I'll be buying.
Worth the ROI.
All I trade is attention, it's
not the medium that I'm romantic
about, it's the value of
attention to create the action
that I'm most passionate about.
("The Celebration Song"
by Brock Berrigan)